[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'ai fait une
crise cardiaque
nadim transplantés
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu te sens différente arrive
à sentir que c'est pas le tien voudrais
juste pouvoir reprendre ma vie d'avant
c'est juste trop bizarre que quelqu'un
ait dû mourir pour que je reste en vie
merci votre fille elle a sauvé david
sachant que j'ose à peine imaginer ce
par quoi vous êtes passé je veux
seulement que vous sachiez qu'on fera
tout notre possible pour honorer sa
mémoire avec dedans si nous avons créé
une bourse d'études monde béquilles on
aimerait offrir cette bourse d'étude à
sa charge méfie-toi de cette famille
[Applaudissements]
je veux connaître qui est à l'intérieur
je vois des choses des choses que ma
donneuse voyait
oh [ __ ]
tiens vraiment bizarre
[Musique]
mais je suis sûr qu'un jour quand on y
repensera on se dira que cette
malheureuse crise cardiaque aurait été
la meilleure chose qui me soit arrivée
[Musique]